vous connaissez les plus célèbres le csa
la cnil ou encore la mf qui régule les
marchés financiers en france
mais connaissez-vous la fld ou le hce rs
tous ces organismes sont ce qu'on
appelle des autorités administratives
indépendantes des hayes
c'est un objet juridique non identifiés
des autorités comme celle ci il en
existe 42 en france financé par l'argent
public
elle coûte 600 millions d'euros par an
malgré des pouvoirs considérables elles
ne sont soumises à aucune autorité
politique
nous avons une capacité d'action et
c'est ce qui nous rend unique
depuis une dizaine d'années c'est à y
poussent comme des champignons
il en est créé une part il devient
évident que cela n'est pas raisonnable
une commission denquête au sénat a
décidé de se pencher sur ces autorités
qui les contrôles sont elles toutes
vraiment utile vous allez voir qu'il
existe des dysfonctionnements et parfois
des abus il y a quelques années
marie a été licencié à cause de sa
grossesse lorsqu'elle annonce à son
employeur qu'elle est enceinte elle a
commencé par subir de petites vexations
comme la suppression de sa place de
parking
et puis peu avant son départ en congé
son employeur la convoque le couperet
tombe aux mains licenciés la veille de
mon congé maternité alors que j'étais en
simple de quasiment 7 mois je
n'imaginais pas qu'on puisse licencier
encore en france une femme enceinte
une sanction qui va avoir des
répercussions sur sa santé mon bébé a
souffert de souffrance foetale pendant
la grossesse
il salue également des conséquences sur
ma santé après l'accouchement
puisque j'ai sombré dans une dépression
g n'ayant plus de travail
marie prend alors un avocat pour saisir
le conseil des prud'hommes
elle se renseigne aussi sur internet et
découvre l'existence du défenseur des
droits
elle décide alors de faire appel à cette
instance car elle s'estime victime d'une
discrimination liée à sa grossesse c'est
une partie du dossier de procédure à la
fois en première instance la cour
d'appel et ça ne met qu'une partie le
défenseur des droits va instruire son
dossier et donner un avis juridique au
tribunal
il estime qu'elle a bien été victime de
discrimination
donc ça c'est de ce courrier c'est le
sont les conclusions du défenseur des
droits qui ont été adressées en amont de
la procédure de première instance
je reste persuadé que l'intervention du
défenseur des droits vous a aidé à avoir
une écoute attentive de notre dossier
et ça m'a permis d'être réhabilité dans
mon dans mon post dans mon travail
il faut reconstruire pedro et de me
reconstruire tout à fait aujourd'hui
marie a gagné en première instance et en
appel
son employeur a été condamné à lui
verser des dommages et intérêts mais il
veut se pourvoir en cassation
et dossiers comme celui de marie les
services du défenseur des droits en
reçoivent près de 70000 chaque année on
peut donc avoir des réclamations qui
nous viennent directement de la part des
personnes qui ont elles mêmes constituer
leur dossier
et puis on a des dossiers qui nous
arrivent directement de la part des
conseils des avocats des des réclamants
discrimination à l'emploi ou encore
difficultés d'accès aux soins relations
avec l'administration où les forces de
l'ordre chaque fois qu'un citoyen estime
que ses droits sont bafoués
il peut saisir cette autorité par écrit
ou sur internet les professionnels ce
qui aide les personnes victimes de
discriminations les associations les
avocats ou maintenant le réflexe de
saisir le défenseur des droits le
défenseur des droits donne donc un avis
juridique sur les dossiers qu'il reçoit
il peut aussi demander des réformes
lorsqu'ils estiment que la loi est mal
faite
l'homme qui incarne c'est pouvoir depuis
juillet 2014 c'est jacques toubon ancien
garde des sceaux et ancien député nommé
pour six ans est irrévocable il estime
que cette fonction exige une
indépendance absolue
mes propositions par définition elles ne
relèvent pas d'une opinion politique
d'une idéologie politique elle ne
représente pas un intérêt particulier
je ne suis pas un groupe de pression je
ne suis pas une association je ne suis
pas une ong qui défendent des intérêts
particuliers
non je le dis au nom de l'intérêt
général et au nom des principes du droit
le défenseur des droits c'est ce qu'on
appelle une autorité administrative
indépendante une entité à part dans
l'organisation de l'état en france
tout a commencé au début des années 70
la grande date c'est la loi de 1973 qui
a créé le médiateur de la république en
france
en s'inspirant du modèle suédois
l'ombudsman qui est l équivalent du
médiateur donc une autorité
administrative qui étaient là pour
réguler les rapports entre les citoyens
et l'administration et donc qui de fait
doit être un peu un tiers par rapport à
l'administration qui étaient autonomes
qui était indépendante et ça a été la
première autorité administrative
indépendante en france même si on ne
l'avait pas appelé comme ça à cette
époque il faudra attendre 1978 avec la
création de la cnil la commission
nationale de l'informatique et des
libertés pour que l'expression
apparaissent dans la loire principales
dispositions de ce projet la création
d'une commission nationale informatique
et libertés une commission de 12 membres
le rôle de ces douze hommes réprimer les
abus être en quelque sorte les
garde-fous de sept nouvelles bastille
que constituent les quelques 200
ordinateurs utilisés par l'état
ces entités sont totalement inédites
dans le paysage administratif
c'est un objet juridique non identifié
d'une part en raison de sa nature qui
combine une nature purement
administrative sans légitimité sans
élection est aussi en raison de ses
pouvoirs puisque on est face à des
autorités qui finalement exercent les
trois pouvoirs à la fois le pouvoir
législatif et le pouvoir exécutif et le
pouvoir judiciaire ou juridictionnelles
des autorités qui relève du conseil
d'état juge de l'administration
nous avons dans beaucoup de domaines des
besoins de régulation indépendante avec
des pouvoirs qui peuvent être différents
qui peuvent être des pouvoirs de
recommandations des pouvoirs david et
pouvoir de décision des pouvoirs de
sanction des pouvoirs considérables pour
des entités administratives
mais plus étonnant encore ces organes
sont totalement indépendant du pouvoir
politique
l'essentiel de la garantie c'est
l'absence de tutelle l'absence de
pouvoir hiérarchique du ministre sur les
décisions de cette autorité
très vite ce mode de fonctionnement
connaît un succès fulgurant
la création de ces gendarmes se
multiplient pour défendre les droits des
citoyens ou réguler des secteurs
économiques énergie médias santé
télécoms je crois que ces autorités
répondent à un vrai besoin de
modernisation de l'action publique
un besoin d'impartialité de neutralité
de l'action publique et puis dernier
besoin un mode d'intervention plus
souple lézat ils sont désormais partout
on en compte aujourd'hui 42
mais certains s'alarment de ce
désengagement de l'état dans de nombreux
secteurs stratégiques et surtout de la
puissance de ces autorités
le groupe des radicaux de gauche du
sénat a donc demandé la création d'une
commission denquête nous sommes arrivés
aujourd'hui pratiquement à 40,2 autorité
administrative indépendante
il en est créé une part il est bien
évident que cela n'est pas raisonnable
cela n'est pas raisonnable parce que c'
est un délitement de l'état
ce n'est pas raisonnable parce que cela
a un coût nous sommes à un stade
aujourd'hui où cette prolifération pose
problème démocratique pose problème de
contrôle du parlement de la république
voici donc réunis pour cette réunion
fidèles que notre commission denquête
toutes les autorités sont ils des mangas
également en bons du questionnaire
détaillé
une telle procédure oblige les
présidents d'autorités à répondre au
sénateur des sénateurs bien décidé à
faire le tri la commission de sécurité
des consommateurs en président n'est pas
nommé 2014 sur ses quarante deux entités
vous allez voir qu'il existe des
autorités administratives indépendantes
fantôme
c'est ce que nous avons découvert au
cours de notre enquête en nous
intéressant à la commission de la
sécurité des consommateurs
son nom ne vous dit peut être rien
pourtant elle existe depuis 1983 et à
l'époque elle joue un rôle de choix dans
la défense des consommateurs
ici siège la commission de la sécurité
des consommateurs
créé en 1983 cette commission vient de
rendre public son premier rapport annuel
159 requêtes émanant surtout de
particuliers mais aussi d'associations
de professionnels et des pouvoirs
publics
premier exemple un avis sur un savon
liquide chamoux ce à la suite d'une
plainte d'un particulier
dès que nous avons été informés nous
avons aussitôt modifier la peau de façon
à ce que la main à puisse passer malgré
tout sous la peau tout en permettant
de l'utiliser normalement 30 ans après
nous avons cherché à contacter cette
commission sans succès le service de
presse n'a jamais donné suite
nous avons donc décidé de vérifier sur
place à l'adresse indiquée des bureaux
mais impossible d'avoir un interlocuteur
c'est bien ici comme je les considère ce
rendez-vous les autres les marocains se
doit rentrer dans 50 des cas
nous sommes donc rediriger de l'autre
côté de la rue directement dans les
locaux de bercy là non plus un franc
succès
je voudrais prendre rendez vous avec un
temps fait qu'ils ne répondent pas à mon
sens pas l'issue
quelques uns ont jamais casting n'ont
que le service de presse nous avons
finalement reçu un drôle de mail de la
part des services de bercy les postes de
président et de secrétaire général de la
csc sont dépourvus de titulaire depuis
le 7 octobre 2014 pour le premier depuis
le 3 juillet 2014 pour le second dans
ces conditions il est difficile
d'envisager une interview portant sur le
fonctionnement de l'autorité
administrative indépendante une autorité
sans président ni secrétaire général
depuis plus d'un an
une situation plutôt étrange pour
essayer de comprendre nous nous sommes
adressés à l'un des interlocuteurs
privilégiés de cette autorité
une association de consommateurs ça
montre ce document de délitement de fête
commission clairement la csc c'est un
étang n'a pas eu les moyens de
fonctionner avec seulement deux avis
rendu en 2014 et un organigramme sans
tête
la csc est devenu une coquille vide soit
donne à la commission de sécurité des
consommateurs les moyens de fonctionner
et de faire efficacement son travail
soit alors faute de moyens et
d'efficacité eh ben on en tire les
conséquences en supprimant cette
institution mais il ne restera pas moins
que les associations de consommateurs ne
pourront pas à elles seules palier et
bien l'absence de commission de sécurité
des consommateurs
elle a un pouvoir qui est celui
d'émettre des avis des recommandations
qui sont beaucoup plus contraignant que
les simples alertes d'une association de
consommateurs
y at il une volonté politique de faire
taire la csc en tout cas c'est désormais
une autorité fantômes qui a tout de même
coûté 250 mille euros en 2014
la masse salariale elle reste inconnue
une situation jugée aberrante par la
commission d' enquête
quand même le comble qu'il y ait qu'une
autorité administrative indépendante
introuvable manifestement le
gouvernement l'exécutif ne trouve aucun
intérêt à la vie de cette autorité
administrative indépendante mais qu'il
en tire les conclusions la commission d'
enquête du sénat demande donc dans son
rapport de faire le ménage et diviser
par deux le nombre de ses amis il y en a
qui ne devrait pas avoir le statut
d'autorité administrative indépendante
qui pourrait réintégrer simplement le
giron de des services de l'état il y en
a d'autres qui peuvent être regroupées
et il y en a vraiment quelques unes qui
pourraient être supprimés
il faut éviter en matière d'autorité
indépendante les doublons les
redondances et le cas échéant les
compétitions et les rivalités
il ya besoin certainement de
concentration un constat posé par la
commission denquête mais ces
regroupements ne peut venir que d'une
initiative politique
c'est ce qui s'est passé pour le
défenseur des droits à l'origine de
cette institution quatre entités la
haute autorité de lutte contre les
discriminations la halde le médiateur de
la république le défenseur des enfants
et la commission nationale de
déontologie de la sécurité pour éviter
les doublons et réduire la facture en
2011 l'état décide de les faire
fusionner quatre ans plus tard le bilan
est plutôt positif
nous avons fait cette fusion à budget
constant entre les quatre anciennes
institutions et le défenseur des droits
aujourd'hui les agents en charge de la
gestion ont diminué de 40% mais la masse
salariale a augmenté de 6% avec la
fusion et pour cause les écarts de
salaires entre agents atteignait près de
40%
il y a donc eu un nivellement par le
haut le budget global du défenseur des
droits restent donc stables à environ 27
millions d'euros par an
les budgets de ces autorités c'est l'une
des grandes inconnues
on connaît ceux du csa de l'autorité des
marchés financiers ou encore de
l'autorité de la concurrence
mais pour beaucoup ces budgets sont
noyés dans les lignes de compte des
ministères auquel ils sont rattachés
le parlement a les plus grandes
difficultés à répertorier de manière
claire les budgets de chacune de ces
autorités administratives indépendantes
que l'on peut retrouver dans différentes
secteurs dans différents budget le
budget global de ces autorités est
estimé à 600 millions d'euros pour
l'année 2014 ce qui est très faible par
rapport au reste de l'administration
le problème c'est qu'il a augmenté de
10% en cinq ans alors que le reste de
l'état est mise au régime
conclusion pour la commission denquête
il faut que les budgets de ces autorités
soient regroupés dans un seul document
homogène publiés chaque année dans la
loi de finances
nous nous sommes également intéressés
aux pouvoirs considérables de certaines
de ces autorités en particulier celles
qui ont la charge de réguler des
secteurs économiques
c'est le cas du csa le conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel dans la tourmente ces
derniers mois en cause des polémiques
autour de la nomination des présidents
de l'audiovisuel public par cette
autorité
l'arrivée de mathieu gallet à la tête de
radio france en 2014 a créé la surprise
et plus récemment la nomination de
delphine ernotte patronne de france
télévisions a suscité une vague de
critiques ce pouvoir de nomination le
csa l'a récupéré en 2013 sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
une loi avait confié ce rôle au
président de la république
les sénateurs de la commission denquête
ont voulu pointer du doigt ces
dysfonctionnements au cours d'une
audition très tendu
aujourd'hui on arrive à une situation où
le csa est sur la sellette
bon on n'est pas devant un tribunal on
est dans une commission enquête qui qui
avancent sur la question des autorités
mais 82 pendante
je suis pas sûr qu'il faille parler
juste d'ajustement c'est des questions
de fond qu'il faut vraiment se poser
parce qu'en fait vous nommer des
dirigeants que vous allez contrôler
c'est quand même ça vous êtes autorités
de nomination mais vous êtes aussi
autorités de régulation le principe qui
consiste à confier la nomination aux
membres d'un collège d'une autorité
indépendante remonte à 1982 avant d'être
remise en vigueur en 2013
donc il n'y a à cet égard aucune
nouveauté donc le conflit de dire et
qu'on avait pu ressentir moment donné
qu'on avait pointé au niveau de l'état
quelque part on l'a déplacé seulement au
niveau du csa nul ne peut contester je
pense que les choix qui ont été faits
par le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel ont été des choix faits
par les membres et exclusivement les
membres du conseil supérieur audiovisuel
en dehors de toute pression
la commission denquête semblait vouloir
cibler le csa finalement dans son
rapport elle pointe simplement les
pouvoirs contradictoires de cette
autorité mais sans apporter aucune
solution
olivier schrameck correct il convaincu
les sénateurs
rien n'est moins sûr mais pas question
pour la commission denquête de cyber une
autorité en particulier c'est donc la
commission de la culture du sénat qui va
se saisir du dossier
sa présidente catherine morin desailly
veut repenser la procédure actuelle
jugés trop opaques au parlement nous
reviendrons sur cette fois de 2013 qui
est insatisfaisante d'ailleurs on l'a vu
dans le processus de nomination la loi
n'encadre pas suffisamment le processus
de nomination ce qui rend possible toute
dérive
mais encore une fois c'est parce que à
l'époque louable 2013
on peut on faire trop de pouvoir au csa
surtout des pouvoirs contradictoires
mais est ce suffisant pour garantir des
procédures transparentes
nous avons demandé son avis à michel
boyon ancien président du csa il a connu
les deux mode de nomination par le csa
justement et par le président de la
république
s'agissant de la nomination des
présidents de l'audiovisuel public
je vous dire qu'après des années des
années d'expérience je considère qu'il
ya pas de système idéal mais les textes
apporteront jamais à eux seuls une
garantie dans ce domaine
les pouvoirs du csa ont déjà fait
l'objet de 16 loi entre 2009 et 2014
c'est donc le parlement et le
gouvernement qui ont la charge de fixer
le cadre de fonctionnement de ces
autorités mais qui les contrôlent
puisqu'elles sont indépendantes
le minimum c'est que une fois qu'elle
rende une décision
la personne concernée puisse former un
recours devant le juge pour vérifier que
cette décision respecte les règles de
droit le conseil d'état et le juge
il est le juge des décisions qui sont
prises par beaucoup de ses autorités
le conseil d'état mais aussi la cour des
comptes ou la cour de cassation
fournissent un grand nombre de membres
de ces fameuses autorité administrative
indépendante pour éviter de faire appel
à des personnes venant du privé
seulement voilà un président d'autorités
administratives indépendantes sur deux
est issu de ces grands corps d'état
là encore la situation fait grincer des
dents la commission denquête c'est un
milieu c'est très clairement souvent un
entre soi il y en a qui sont membres de
plusieurs autorités administratives
indépendantes c'est pas forcément une
bonne chose que à la fois il est
déconseillé l'état dans presque tous les
collèges et et qu'en même temps les
recours se fasse devant devant le
conseil du temps
jean-marc sauvé vice-président du
conseil d'état garantit pourtant
l'impartialité de cette institution
les membres du conseil d'état qui
servent dans une autorité indépendante
par définition sont sortis du conseil
d'état nous avons une culture de
l'indépendance nous avons une culture de
l'impartialité et nous sommes
parfaitement en capacité de juger toutes
les décisions administratives prises par
les autorités de la république
les sénateurs de la commission denquête
pointe aussi les parcours de certains
présidents d'autorités de malgré leurs
compétences reconnues
c'est le cas de la médiatrice du livre
elle était directrice de cabinet au
ministère de la culture
juste avant de devenir la première
médiatrice en 2014 gallois même date du
17 mars 2014 à un moment où vous dirigez
le cabinet de la ministre de la culture
c'est quand même la première chose qui
m'interpelle mais surtout au niveau de
la notion d'indépendance et vous vous
retrouvez quelques mois après le
médiateur du livre donc considérer vous
vraiment que c'est un mécanisme
d'indépendance les fêtes ne sont pas
contestables j'étais effectivement
directrice de cabinet au moment où la
loi a été voté par au moment où les
décrets d'application ont été pris c'est
pas comme directrice de cabinet que
j'occupe les fonctions de médiateur du
livre bah oui enfin j'allais dire encore
heureux un mais mais quand même c'est
pas si ce processus au niveau des
autorités administratives indépendantes
de de création ne vous interpelle pas en
personnellement ça me pose quand même
problème
alors si si la question que vous vous
posez
c'est celle de savoir si j'ai pu
personnellement intervenir parce que
j'avais comme idée de devenir un jour
médiateur du livre j'ai prêté serment ce
n'était pas le cas et pour le reste la
loi prévoit sa tempe de garantie qui me
paraissent être respectée
rien d'illégal donc mais la commission
denquête réclame un renforcement des
règles de déontologie prévu par la haute
autorité de transparence de la vie
publique notamment sur les conditions
d'arrivée et de départ des membres de
ces autorités
à partir du moment où ce sont des
autorités ça c'est leur nature même
qu'ils n'ont pas de légitimité
démocratique qui ne sont pas composées
de personnes et vu d'où vient leur
légitimité
la légitimité ça passe par la
responsabilité avec le pouvoir vient la
responsabilité
autre proposition de la commission
denquête limiter le recours à ces grands
corps d'état mais sont pour autant dire
qu'ils ont peut nommer à la place
enfin de manière plus concrète elles
demandent de faire appliquer la loi
concernant les déclarations d'intérêts
et de patrimoine des membres de ces
collèges on peut pas imposer aux
parlementaires avec une rigueur certaine
et justifier de respecter ces règles là
et constaté que les membres des collèges
des autorités administratives
indépendantes pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux se refuse à les appliquer
le 4 novembre 2015 la commission
denquête a publié son rapport avec onze
propositions pour mettre de l'ordre dans
ce qu'elle a appelé un état dans l'état
une proposition de loi doit suivre
mais encore faut-il qu'elle soit votée
pour que ces recommandations ne reste
pas lettre morte
et cela pose un autre problème ce sont
les parlementaires qui doivent adopter
ces mesures
une vingtaine d'entre eux siègent aussi
dans des autorités administratives
indépendantes en disant c'est le
troisième rapport qui s'attaque aux high
les publications s'accumulent mais les
lignes bougent très peu